we need
cop the world needs him
it's godzilla
this is our only chance
we have to take
we need kong the world needs him
to stop what's coming
and this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go
so i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
[Music]
it's godzilla
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here am i the same
opinion
the myths are real yeah there was a war
and they're the last one standing for
greatness
no one
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new godzilla versus kong trailer
video they just dropped another new one
just a couple days ago
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing an amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about who
winds up winning during the movie
they've been all kinds of rumors about
them changing the ending depending on
whether or not they're going to renew
their license with touhou
and make more godzilla and kong more
versus movies
for the most part all the rumors about
that are actually pretty good that they
will wind up renewing their license and
we'll see more monster versus movies
they're actually doing a new netflix
anime series set on skull island too so
that just bodes well that they're going
to continue to do more projects
in the monster verse i'll talk about
that at the end of the video too like
where do we go
in the monster vs with the movies after
godzilla vs kong if we're already doing
something with mechagodzilla during this
we also got confirmation on some of the
names of the titans that they're
changing during the movie which other
titans show up during these trailers
but in the new trailer footage they
focus a lot more on the scenes between
this little girl in kong the kong
whisper the alexander skarsgard is
arguing with rebecca hall about like we
have to take her with us she's the only
one he responds to
they haven't really made her origin
clear in the movie she might be a member
of the tribe or
a member of a group that got stranded on
skull island at some point and she just
formed some relationship with him
it had been implied in the last movie
that a lot of people had either been
stranded there or were living there as
natives
so there's a lot of different reasons
why she could have wound up growing up
there
a couple people did clarify what the
deal is with him being called kong and
not king kong though that's actually
because of some legal dispute some
copyright issue that prevents them from
using the king kong name in the movie
but during the last kong movie they did
have that line of dialogue saying that
kong is king around here so they have
referenced him as
king kong even if they can't legit call
him that during the movie
there's a lot more scenes of their first
fight on the ships here footage of
godzilla just straight up destroying or
capsizing the ship that kong is standing
on here he goes into the water and they
want to hype it up like he's drowning
but if you haven't seen the classic
1960s
king kong vs godzilla film a lot of this
is riffing on some moments from that
kong does know how to swim they're just
hyping this part of the fight up for
drama
because we've seen the godzilla is just
as powerful in the water as he is on
land
he uses that ancient underwater coverage
system to travel quickly around the
world like an underwater expressway
system
fast pass and we've only ever really
seen this version of kong fight when
he's got ground to stand on
even in the lakes and the rivers that he
walks around on in skull island he's so
big that they're like puddles to him so
the idea is that godzilla would have a
natural advantage in deep water where
kong's center of gravity is upended
and at this point in the movie it
doesn't seem like kong has this battle
axe yet
but as you can see in some of the other
trailer footage you see kong get a
couple good swipes in like he's got
those twin pythons on him and he does
not skip leg days
whereas godzilla has those stubby little
arms and has to make up for a lack of
traditional brawling skills with his
big tail swipes and special energy
attacks like his atomic breath of the
nuclear pulse
or his super strong armor scales so
really what kong would need to do is
just get
godzilla in a grapple and then take him
down before
godzilla has time to charge any of his
special abilities
but the way the rest of this first fight
goes down it seems like godzilla's able
to get a really good swipe in and just
cold clock kong
almost like a tko and godzilla is the
clear winner of this
boat fight which seems like it's from
pretty early in the movie
then in the new trailer there's a couple
other new fight scenes there might
actually be
three different fight scenes in the
trailer here because there's a bunch
more footage of the hong kong fight
where godzilla lands this solid tail
swipe on kong and knocks him through a
couple high rises
but then there's completely different
looking scenes of kong in the daylight
after a fight looking like he's been
knocked out cold by godzilla or
mechagodzilla and it's hard to tell if
this is after the same hong kong fight
or a totally different one
they really really want you to think
that kong gets his ass
beat in this movie from all the ways
they've cut this trailer it just feels
like a total misdirect though
like clearly the little girl here gives
him some epic pep talk
and he revives like you see him stand up
and start screaming amidst all this
rubble in the daylight
like this is meant to be a big rally
moment for him the way that godzilla had
a big rally moment during godzilla king
of monsters against ghidorah
but it's really hard to tell if this
fight scene is from the end of the movie
because sometimes studios will do that
surprisingly like you wouldn't think
that they would give away the ending of
the movie but i think the way they've
cut this they're just trying to be as
misleading as possible about when this
is actually happening
there's been all kinds of competing
rumors about who winds up winning this
fight
depending on what happens with future
godzilla and kong films future monster
verse films but like i said i think it's
all good news like they will
continue to use these characters in the
future and if you didn't watch the
classic 1960s king kong vs godzilla film
the funny thing about that is that there
are actually two different versions of
the movie and depending on which version
of the movie you watch
a different monster winds up winning the
fight are seeming like they come out on
top
but really the movie winds up ending in
a kind of ambiguous way with both kong
and godzilla going their separate ways
like you see him swimming off here back
to skull island
so we might wind up with a similar
situation with godzilla versus kong
because i think we're all expecting them
to do the big tag team against
mechagodzilla
take that down and then maybe they go
their separate ways
we also get a little more footage of
kong with his special acts they're just
calling it a battle axe here but it
looks like it's made from one of the
bones of maybe a mudo and obviously
godzilla's dorsal spike and it can
absorb his atomic breath
making it even more powerful and in the
way that they're giving kong this new
special weapon they're giving godzilla
new special attacks during the movie too
but that might have something to do with
maybe a magnetic base attack because of
mechagodzilla
something to help him fight
mechagodzilla but according to the movie
the whole idea with mechagodzilla is
that apex creates it as a way to end
what they're calling the reign
of the monsters so to speak because the
way they've been canonizing the monsters
in the ancient history of the earth with
these ancient cultures that worship them
like gods
is that humanity is basically like the
pets of the monsters
so whereas during godzilla king of
monsters you have all these
eco-terrorists running around the world
trying to unleash the monsters on the
earth
to return it to this natural state apex
as an organization
seems like it wants to end the reign of
the monster so to speak
maybe also profit off them quite a bit
the way they hyped it up during king of
monsters
is that there are so many different
things that you can do with titan
biology you can create weapons
medicines pretty much anything you could
possibly imagine
but some of the other new titans that
they've confirmed just based on the way
they're selling these toys here they
have skull crawler toys that they're
selling for the movie
so maybe there's some flashbacks with
skull crawlers to the events of kong
skull island or maybe we see some new
ones during the movie
these titans that you see him swinging
around on skull island are now being
called
war bats the snake-like flying titans
the ones that look like the classic bat
titans in the trailer they're just
calling those hell
hawks the secret one that's all covered
up the exclusive a
is probably a version of mechagodzilla
just based on the outline
an exclusive b might be a logo or a
patch designed for apex or it could be
another mystery titan
but in terms of the future of the
monsterverse movies like where do we go
after godzilla vs kong there's always
the idea that they do another
like full-blown battle royale war of the
monsters like they keep referencing this
ancient war of the monsters
they could be building up to a bigger
version of that and if they don't want
to escalate things to a full-blown war
of the monsters yet
they could just introduce other big
titans they haven't done yet like
destoroyah
there were also a lot of rumors about
them thinking about doing crossovers
with the pacific rim franchise because
that's another legendary franchise
but if they wanted to get that crazy
with it they probably have to shift the
time period to the future so you
wouldn't have millie bobby brown
or a lot of the characters from present
day in those movies they have to
introduce a brand new cast
but everyone posts all your theories
about godzilla vs kong
on the video and let me know what do you
want them to do with future monster
verse movies
i've got some new wanda vision that i'm
working on my one division episode 7
video will also post friday they're also
going to be releasing the first big
mortal kombat movie trailer tomorrow so
i'll be doing a video for that as well
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of those
you can click here for my one division
episode 7 trailer video
and you can click here for that brand
new justice league snyder cut trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you